um so without further Ado um I want to
jump in and think about um
orchestrating um generative AI workflows
uh and and what this what what this even
means so thinking about really the full
stack of generative AI but first I want
to think about how we build machine
learning software right um and how that
changes from uh building traditional
software okay so in order to reason
through this
I want to think about the stack of
machine learning software kind of all
the tools we need to to use right um so
let's think through how differ from
traditional software um and to do that
let's start looking at traditional
software so you have a software engineer
and some sort of software uh system uh
ideally a valuable system we can think
of how to slice this in a variety of
ways um but two things that we
definitely require of any software
system is that it will run reliably with
without human supervision so where I to
build it and wanted to go and have
dinner um and close my laptop we'd want
it to run reliably for you or the end
user we also want it to produce correct
results so these are two uh incredibly
important aspects of any uh traditional
software system that we still require
when we go to machine learning and data
um and AI powered software
right but what changes within this
system so we have several new components
right we have um we have data we have
machine learning models we also have a
new role of a data scientist um and a
new role that has a vastly different
skill set as well the skills of a of a
data scientist are very different to the
skills of a a classical uh software
software engineer right so we're going
to see how that's important in terms of
kind of the stack that we in interact
with as data scientists and machine
learning
Engineers so what are the building
blocks that we then have right we have
data models and code and they need to
interact act in a variety of ways so now
we're going to see kind of the
implications of the the requirement that
they they interact right so in order for
our data to interact with our models we
require computation to happen somewhere
you know when doing exploratory data
analysis and first building
experimenting with models that compute
may happen on your local workstation on
your laptop um but after a while
particularly if you're doing generative
AI stuff which is Computing intensive
maybe you're going to start leveraging
Cloud resources so compute um is
essential on top of that orchestration
uh becomes increasingly important and
that's why we called this talk um
orchestrating in in a lot of ways right
um that when you write code to build
models you know you can do fit and
predict do some feature engineering
these types of things using you know
your favorite wonderful packages such as
psychic learn or XG boost or pie torch
right um but there comes a point where
once you're putting models in production
we'll talk about what that means soon
but once you're putting models in
production um you know maybe you're
doing uh massive hyperparameter
optimization feature engineering data
validation training different models on
joins of different data sets these these
types of things and you want to start
putting um orchestrating the these
models Through The Code by putting them
in some sort of graph if you've had
experience with data engineering or
these types of workflows maybe you've
seen uh directed a cyclic graphs or or
dags but this is kind of the standard of
how we think about orchestrating machine
learning models as well but you
orchestration becomes increasingly
important
now as I said these models are built by
humans such as yourself and and myself
right with a particular skill set a
scientific uh skill set one of iteration
and rapid prototyping right um so when
building models maybe you're jumping in
notebooks at the start in order to
rapidly prototype your models um and
you're generating a lot of data yourself
um so you need to start thinking about
versioning now not only versioning your
code you may be you may have version
code before um but now you're thinking
about versioning all the data that
you're um working on and versioning your
models as well so let's say you've got a
model in production at some point which
produces an incorrect result and you
want to um you want to root cause this
essentially figure out what happened you
want to be able to trace it back to the
data to the actual model you used the
Run uh that that you used um uh when you
trained it and then the data that it was
trained on perhaps you have data that's
updating daily right you want to take go
back and be able to find the actual data
set that that you trained it on so
versioning is increasingly
important now to connect all of these
things to your valuable Software System
you need to deploy the model in some
sense um which you know a lot of people
think of this as
productionize process is really think
what it means to have a model in in
production now the deployment story I
think a lot of people tend to think this
means setting up an API that people can
ping or you can you know build into an
application right something like that
that's one of many ways to deploy a
model um a lot of models involve batch
inference where you know at the end of a
day or end of a week uh the models run
and um all the all the predictions are
stored in a data warehouse or something
along those lines or um you can have
um you know the deployment story told by
a slide deck being generated and sent to
Executives that then use it to make uh
uh business decisions or a weekly email
that's generated and sent to the team so
deployment all I'm really saying there
is that deployment can take uh many
forms and and
flavors
um so then what has emerged here is a
more nuanced view of the machine
learning infrastructure stack and we're
about to get into to you know what what
changes and what doesn't when we uh work
with generative AI right um but we have
uh data at the bottom then compute
orchestration versioning deployment
modeling at the top um and the truth of
the matter is that you know there's a
lot to work with here and a lot of
different things need to be done and
data scientists really care about the
top of the stack um but a significant
amount of infrastructure is required at
the bottom um and you may say wait Hugo
um it looks like you're saying data
scientists don't care about data at all
um and that's not what I'm saying at all
but it's a great question if that if
that came to mind I mean it's a great
question anyway and I I hear it a lot
right but the point here of course data
scientists care um a huge amount about
data um what isn't necessarily their
most important concern is how the data
engineering pipelines work whether it's
stored in a data warehouse or coming
from parket uh files on S3 uh these
types of things right um and if a data
scientist does start to care about these
things um significantly to be honest
they're kind of becoming a data engineer
and that's totally cool and actually I
support a lot of data scientists who
transition to data engineering roles um
but and I've seen this happen a lot
right um but really I'm talking about
the the data engineering side side of
things here um and so of course um data
ssts care about data but they want to
use it for a very practic purpose which
is to build build models and put them in
production so in a second we're going to
jump into generative AI but I wanted to
talk about metaflow which is an open
source framework that I work on with my
colleagues at out of bounds and um and
and Netflix so this is a framework that
um my
colleagues um when they ran machine
learning infrastructure at
Netflix uh built in 2017 then open
sourced in 2019 um and now it's used uh
by by hundreds of companies all across
the globe um in all types of verticals
um but I wanted to show some metaflow
code just to give a sense of how you can
I mean this is pi dat I want to give a
sense of how you can write pythonic code
um and python code not only pythonic but
python code um but pythonic as well um
in in order to interact with the full
stack of machine learning in in in this
sense so um what we have is um where
writing a class um and we're subclassing
flow speec here where the steps in your
machine learning workflow we've got two
steps here start and end so this is um
you know a very simplified example um
but what we see is that um to tell the
modeling part of the story right um
there's a decorator at cond base where
at a flow level you can Define the
libraries that you want to use so we've
got a particular version of psychic
psychic learn here okay you can also
Define if you have different um packages
at different steps you can Define them
and maybe you know for resourcing you
want to do that at different steps in
terms of deployment you can use lots of
different decorators you can use but at
schedule we make sure that this is
deployed um daily at a particular
Cadence and there are defaults but you
can also specify what you'd like to um
terms of versioning if you assign a
variable to
um assign an in here for example to uh
an an in instance variable um this will
um make sure that self.x persists across
steps um and also that it's stored in
the metadata service um so you're able
um to after the fact access all all of
these all of these variables um the
whole thing is the directed I cyclic
graph so the whole thing is the
orchestration story in terms of compute
um if I didn't have this decorator by
default all of this would run locally if
I have a step such as you know let's say
I want to do some pretty significant you
know generative AI training for example
I can use an kubernetes decorator and
specify me the memory that I require in
order to send that to to the cloud um
and uh in terms of data this is once
again how we interact with data so we're
incrementing self.x by one here um and
you can work with all types of you know
data and data types um from all types of
data warehouses and parket files and all
of these all of these things but what I
want to make clear is that um you know
my background is in research science and
I want to make sure that scientists have
access to the tools software tools that
help them do their work the best um so I
want to make sure that data scientists
and ml Engineers aren't required to go
and work with narly kubernetes clusters
and set them up and write configuration
files in yaml and all of these types of
things so that's why I'm really excited
about you know this type of ionic
decorator based uh resource acquisition
so being able to write at kubernetes in
order to um get access to a cluster
that's been provisioned for you is super
important to to me as as a human so all
our scientists can do our our best work
um and very happy to to to chat more
about that type of thing um but we're
here to talk about generative AI right
and by generative AI I really mean all
the wonderful llms we're seeing all the
speech to text all the like text to
image text to video all of these
incredible things that we're seeing so
how does this how how do these things
change um data workflows currently okay
so firstly um I think it's important to
just reason through um you know an a
potential example there are many ways we
can we can think about this but um we
know for example um
that a lot of the time will be ping
vendor apis uh and or um using uh open
source Foundation models so in this
example we have a customer service
chatbot and a product that's powered by
um a lot of this generative AI stuff so
we have
um an uh open source Foundation model
which where perhaps we fine-tuning the
large language model then using it to
generate some embeddings and then
powering a customer service chatbot
using this we also have stuff coming in
from a data warehouse this may be may be
prompts or themes or whatever it is um
these things are also feeding
personalized
recommendations um which are being
stored in the same or different data
warehouse which are then uh used to
power a product the product also
involves image generation which we're
getting from uh a vendor um and we're
generating images putting them in cloud
storage and using that to uh Power power
the product as well right now one thing
I I want you all to be thinking more and
more about is the risk you're taking on
and the cost when adopting uh such
things as AI vendor apis and open source
Foundation models um so for example
thinking even through um latency
concerns cost future proofing what
you're doing um because these things are
outside your governance boundary you do
not necess like there are terms of
service with AI vendors but you do not
control what their model are or what's
what what's happening happening there
and similarly open source Foundation
models perhaps you have a bit more um
knowledge of what's what's going on but
a lot of the time open source you don't
even know what the training data is uh
but you do have access to the weights
and not necessarily uh the code um so
start thinking about the type of uh
affordances risks and benefits of um of
what what you're what you're taking on
um and also I just wanted to say I'm
seeing uh hey Tom thanks so much um
great to great great to see you watching
from Austin but I just wanted to say
it's so cool to have so many people from
you know we've got UK and Greece
Seattle um Austin uh Hungary it's it's
really cool to to see a whole bunch of
people from around the world um a lot of
countries represented here so great to
see you
all so in terms of the stack you know
we've got data versioning compute
orchestration modeling deployment all
these things right the question does the
stack remain the same um when we move
from machine learning to generative AI
um and I argue that it that it does some
of the details uh differ a lot but we
still you know data is a foundational
concern we require our data to be
flowing in dags we require secure access
we require fast Cloud apis similarly
compute is important and you may say and
I would totally agree that although
these things remain the same some are
weighted more heavily now so currently
compute is even more more important
right so we need pretty serious
processes in gpus parallelization low
latency apis um we definitively need to
still be telling the orchestration story
we need to be reacting to new data we
need to be H handling failures
gracefully we need to be able to
checkpoint and resume our flows as
well the versioning story I is still
incredibly important if not more so
um it's not obvious to me how this will
play out I mean of course we need to
version our prompts and have prompt
management we need to have you know
different different and isolated name
spaces so we can trace back and see what
what's happened where um we're
generating a lot of artifacts that we
need to version as well and what I mean
is I'm not sure how this is going to
play out is in the versioning
story pregenerative
AI a lot not all but a lot of what we
were generating is quote unquote
structure structured data right and now
we have a huge amount of natural
language and images and videos that
we're we're generating and it's not
clear to me that more and more we're
creating like natural language data um
how we want to think about versioning um
and so this is It's fascinating but it's
it's um kind of scary in a lot of ways
as well maybe that's a it's as I said
it's 8 a.m. on a Saturday so maybe I'm
prone to to fear more than at other
other points in time but um I I do think
it's it it's challenging um the
deployment story is still of course key
um and so is modeling right um you know
people still want to use their favorite
packages we've got really cool open
source Foundation models now to you to
use um increasingly we're thinking about
um calling external external libraries
and AI vendor apis which is kind of a
new part of the story when doing full
setep machine learning most of the time
we're using open source packages right
that's no longer the case now
um and you want to do all of this in a
manner that makes engineers and happy to
right um so in the final 10 minutes I
want to talk about um the types of
um generative AI systems that we're
talking about and then some some key
concerns okay so it was like last August
I know maybe earlier last June that um
stable
diffusion came came on the scene and
kind of blew us all away and you know
these are these are some images we
generated with metlow out of bounds of
Nicholas Cage's Thor Superman Hercules
and the
Godfather um I never I never quite got
my own joke here of course um you may
know that Nicholas Cage is a coppler his
um Francis Ford cppa is his uncle so it
even makes even more sense to um put him
as The Godfather there um but um this is
compute intensive um stuff generating
the these type types of images um and so
what we did um was I mean there were a
lot of proof of concept around at the
time as as there is with a lot of
generative AI not a lot of being able to
productionize it so what we figured out
and and published and you can um go to
our our blog and I've got Links at the
end of this talk that I'll I'll show you
um and you can go to um how to
parallelize stable diffusion um for
production use cases and these are types
of dags I was talking about recently
where you start you upload the model to
S3 then you generate images um in
different styles as here then you paint
the cards then you join the cards join
the style and and and and you can see
you know where're using hugging face and
Docker and Nvidia gpus and and that type
of stuff there
um so now this this is you're getting a
snake peek into something we haven't
published yet that we'll publish I think
in a few days um so definitely ping me
on slack I I'll send you a link to our
community slack at the end of this talk
as well but um a few weeks ago um stable
video diffusion was released which is
image to video and these are images
we've generated I mean this is wild to
me I don't want to I mean stability AI
released stable video diffusion a few
weeks ago then um we we were attempting
to replicate um
our stable diffusion work in video uh
then they release stable diffusion XL
which is a new version of stable
diffusion and we're able to switch that
out um pretty much pretty much
immediately um which is is super
exciting but you know in if you have
access to compute and kind of robust
orchestrators like metaflow um you're
able to generate these types of things
with relative ease to be to be clear um
and you know I mean this the these
images are sorry these videos are pretty
I wouldn't quite say it's Pixar or
Disney level but I mean some of them are
getting really close so I I think it's a
fascinating space um so we're building
an app which it in the end put outputs
things like this that you can play
around with but it starts with prompts
and themes you want to load your your
data then use text to image and image to
video to generate the images uh serve
them to cloud storage and then have them
accessible um this is a dag of the types
of things we're doing where you can see
once again we upload the models generate
images generate videos from images join
subjects um and this is uh some pseudo
code it's pretty close um you know where
we have data in our data warehouse um
and we uh trigger it um then we generate
the videos and then we have our gpus and
visualization and and clusters up up
there um so so this stuff is a lot of
fun to work with so keep your eyes
peeled um we've also been doing work uh
with speech to text models such as open
AI whisper um on on kubernetes to to put
them in production which is super fun um
a lot of large language models um so
fine-tuning
llms um which this is essentially taking
uh found Foundation models and then
making them um
making them uh work on more specific
data sets um so that um so that they can
become more specific and more relevant
to your actual concerns um another
technique for doing this which doesn't
require anywhere near as much compute as
fine-tuning is a really fun technique
that um actually that we spent you know
half of a workshop we taught here at at
P Global on on on yesterday um going
through so the basic um idea is it's a
way of controlling llms and making uh
the output a lot more relevant um by
approaching the problem at inference
time not during training um so you
essentially index a knowledge base and
use it to increase the relevance of llm
responses so we did an example where we
ask chat GPT um how do
you um specify packages for a machine
learning workflow and it gave us a
general answer around cond we wanted a
metap specific one and so we use
retrieval augmented generation with all
the metaphor documentation uh to get out
um the answer and it gave us the at cond
base decorator that I mentioned earlier
so I do want to uh speak to a few uh
challenges and then how we're thinking
about ways ways forward um one of the
biggest concerns is that um large
language models tend to um hallucinate
uh and we'll go into what that means in
a second um we've got data freshness
issues we need to constantly update um
questions of Clos versus open apis and
then the cost of of fine tuning so in
the final five minutes we started five
minutes late so we're going to go five
five minutes over um but um what do we
say when we mean hallucinate and what I
mean by that is left to their
pre-training uh data sets generic llms
will gladly generate nonsense and oh
yeah this is so um my this is work we
did with our uh collaborator Frederico
uh biani at at Stanford and so that's
him there and so he asked how do I
specify condo dependencies in my flow in
metaflow um and this answer is wrong
this is so this is nonsense but if you
didn't know perhaps um perhaps you you'd
try it and not know
um so the level of deviation from any
trusted database is actually um
unacceptable so how how do we then um
figure figure this out and we can deal
with it by uh what I mentioned earlier
this idea of fine tuning or in in
instruction tuning here okay so we can
um continue training the model on a much
more tightly curated data set teaching
it how to do specific things like follow
uh these instructions
um so compared to you know the size of
pre-training data sets this can
drastically uh narrow the model scope
and Lead it to generate far more
relevant responses um which is super
cool um the other uh way that I me
already mentioned is using retrieval
augmented
Generation Um so oh oops um another
challenge is that
um models don't have access to to fresh
data um so you know it's depending on
you know
when chat gbt has updated recently for
you um it may it may be you know most
recently trained on 2021 2022 or or more
recent data um but a huge problem is
that um these models aren't necessarily
always always updated um so how do we
think about that um and what we can do
is put highly relevant data in databases
and use for example our at schedule
decorator in order to um do instruction
tuning fine tuning and or retrieval
augmented uh generation on a regular
Cadence in order
to to update our our um large language
models so that they have current and
relevant uh
data um now this is this is a fun one
there are so many models um I think I'm
pretty sure by you know most metrics AI
is the fastest moving technology in
human history um so in order to stay in
business we need to uh increasingly
learn to um adapt and figure out what's
happening in in the space a lot of the
time the commercial API is expedient
open source requires more effort um but
open source also lets you own more of
the supply chain and have more control
so as I mentioned before thinking
through you know do performing a cost
benefit analysis of what models you're
using and why um is incredibly
important um right um and one way to
think about you know solving the
challenges here are to um reduce
dependencies on single points of failure
in the software supply chain right um so
um how we think about that at metaflow
and out of bounds is making sure that
you're able to to swap models in and out
so this is an example of
um
swapping out Lance DB for pine cone
another one I I saw recently that um we
have um there are some metaflow users
here in Sydney actually who I gave a
talk with recently they've got an online
learning platform called atomy um that's
used in a lot of high schools super cool
stuff and they were using chat gbt and
they recently uh switched it out with
almost no migration cost for um llama 2
which is an open source model from
Facebook from meta um company forly
known as as Facebook um so thinking
about making these easily composable
flows where you can switch things in and
out um is increasingly important um cost
um is uh really important to to think
through and when we're doing
fine-tuning
um uh it's something that you really
need to need to consider because it can
be incredibly expensive um and so
thinking through reducing costs from
model optim ization um using such
techniques as quantization and and Laura
low rank optimization um and this is
kind of a whirlwind tour of these types
of things but when you start
implementing these things these are the
types of things you need to need need to
think about so just to recap um and then
we'll wrap up um the challenges that LMS
hallucinate you can solve that and think
about solving that by augmenting um its
context with your data um data freshness
is a challenge that you can think about
scheduling um and event-based workflows
for uh updating your models um to think
about Clos vers open apis um we have
reusable workflow uh abstractions um
which allow them their modular and allow
you to switch out um uh closed and open
models for each other um and to work
through and and solve uh the expenses of
fine-tuning you want to think a lot
about model
optimization so um to wrap up I do I
would I'd have to fire myself if I uh
didn't tell you how you can do this at
home um check out the metaflow
documentation at docs. meta flow. org
for all the open source stuff um also
check out the sandbox so this is what we
went through in in the tutorial
yesterday um setting up a lot lot of the
infrastructure stuff such as kubernetes
clusters and deployments is highly
non-trivial so we've built um a Sandbox
where you can interact with all the um
open source infrastructure that we we
work on as well you can think about it
as a like a Google collab for uh machine
learning infrastructure full State
machine learning and an AI or you can
think about it as kind of a superpowered
in browser vs code where you can write
code execute it you've got your
terminals all of these types of things
um and we have a lot of different
tutorials that speak to a lot of the
content I presented today from audio
processing with whisper to computer
vision NLP recommended systems um where
we've set up everything including
kubernetes clusters for you to you you
to play around with okay okay um and
finally um if you want to chat about
this type of stuff um come and say hi on
slack uh this is our our slack link um
and actually we've got over 3,000 data
scientists machine learning Engineers
all trying met all this Fun open source
stuff and you can DM me or my colleague
Eddie um at Hugo Eddie but if you ask
questions in public as well then a lot
of different people can can answer them
um so once again thank you so much for
for joining thank you for sticking
around until uh the end of the the
conference as well and I'd love to thank
pida once again for for having us it's
it's a real pleasure
always thank you so much Hugo that was
in a great talk I think I speak for
everyone thank you so much for your your
expertise and your time um I really
quickly want to bring to your attention
one question um great presentation Hugo
will it be possible to get the slides
from ad oh yeah why don't I actually I
will share this slide deck right right
now
um copy link and what I'll do is anyone
with the link cannot
edit I'll give
everyone great question and I've just
pasted this in the in the chat would you
Sam would you
just confirm that yep I see that
beautiful I'll go ahead and pin it too
um I will say that the chat gets cleared
at the end of the session um but I'll
leave a minute real quick and I'll say
my thanks so thank you so much for
everyone joining today um as we close Pi
dat Global uh I just want to really
profess my love for the community and on
behalf of all the organizers and
speakers thank you for joining us um I
saw a question about seeing Hugo's uh
tutorial recording from yesterday so if
y'all are curious or you missed a
session that you were hoping to see in
airmeet uh you can rewatch any session
until the end of the year we're giving
y'all until January 1st 2024 afterwards
they'll be uploaded to the Piata YouTube
channel um so you can find it there and
we have a feedback survey that would be
awesome if y'all could fill it out in
the Discord um yeah thank you
again awesome thanks SAA once again and
thanks
everyone real quick sorry uh hug go one
more quick question I just want to make
sure we get everyone's bases covered uh
m is asking what is your advice on the
cyber security within the llm Gen AI any
link within llm gen AI any links
um
this this is a really important question
and I I think we we don't have a strong
sense of How It's playing out currently
I do I do have a a link let me
um
so I think
one one
thing we think
about a lot is software Supply chains
and vulnerability in software Supply
chains so we actually we've been working
with um a wonderful company called
chainu guard I've just linked to a blog
post from from from chainu guard um but
essentially this is uh a post around um
these these types of questions um about
how
um adoption of Open Source tools and
vendor apis interacts with the type of
security concerns you have and I think
one thing that's becoming increasingly
important is to identify vulnerabilities
at each different step in in this in in
the machine learning supply chain um but
check out that that blog and come and
chat with us on slack about it as well
if you want